I know I saw statue of Samuel Adams I
saw his grave too
we rode on a Swan the Swan was a pedal
foot pedal bike both Swan but it was
really neat and you know most of all
what I remember was arriving at the
school and having all the kids chanting
my name I mean seriously it's like stuff
like that makes you think is this truly
my life do you get a chance to ever play
tourists like this very often I mean I
love taking trips but I would say that
yeah I mean if I get one trip a year
that's great but I'm still not that
great of a tourist like I like to do
things but you know the education of a
city is probably something that I could
do a better job at so it was an honour
for the kids to put in the effort to
write about all the different spots that
we stopped at and and do some public
speaking and and and say it on the
loudspeaker for everyone to hear
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You Josh yeah